if you were going for a refreshing swim
the last thing you'd expect is to
suffocate from toxic gases
but when it comes to lake kivu
this is one dangerous body of water you
wouldn't want to dive into
what makes this lake so hazardous
what would the physical consequences of
swimming in it be
and how could the lake be on the verge
of toxic explosion
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you fell into lake kivu
lake kivu is on the border of the
democratic republic of congo and rwanda
it covers 2700 kilometers and is one of
the african great lakes
but it has a dangerous twist
it contains about 55 billion cubic
meters of methane and carbon dioxide
yeah the lake sits on top of active
volcanic hot springs so these gases
accumulate in the deepest layers of the
lake at a depth of around 300 meters
usually these gases would bubble out but
because they're so deep under the lake
waters they're under high pressure
that makes them denser than the layers
of water above and the gases can't rise
to the surface
but what if this fragile system
shattered and the toxic gas suddenly
went to the surface
and what if you happen to fall into lake
kivu at that moment
if you fell into lake kivu the first
thing you'd notice is how warm it is oh
at the surface the water temperature is
around 24 degrees celsius
if you were to dive deeper
you'd be in for a surprise
typically water in a lake gets colder
the deeper you go
this process is known as convection
cold dense surface water sinks while
warm less dense water rises
but in lake kivu it's the opposite
you'd feel the temperature rising as you
went down
you'd also notice that the water divides
into two sections
there's the low density water above 60
meters and the dense saline heavy lower
level
these two layers hardly mix
the lower levels have been sitting near
the bottom untouched for thousands of
years
it's this bottom layer of the lake that
might kill you
the gases stored in the deep lake water
could suddenly release creating a toxic
gas cloud
this is a limnic eruption
eruptions like this have devastating
effects but they are rare with only two
in recorded history
the most disastrous one was at lake nios
in cameroon in 1986
a large toxic cloud of carbon dioxide
suddenly spread to nearby villages and
asphyxiated 1800 people now if this
happened at lake kivu it would be even
worse
lake kivu is larger than nios
the death rate of an eruption here would
be extremely high
and of course you'd be at the center of
it
how could you tell it was about to erupt
well the water would be saturated with
gases
additional gas would bubble out and mix
with the atmosphere
the soil would be dry a drought would
indicate that something terrifying was
brewing inside lake kivu
the water would start to evaporate and
the pressure at the bottom would
decrease and the lake would release more
gases
things would get even worse if there was
an earthquake
it would happen with little warning and
wreak havoc in numerous ways
it would shake the layers of water like
a can of soda and when that can opens it
would release carbon dioxide
and the bad news wouldn't end there
there would also be methane bubbling out
of the lake
as the methane mixed with the
surrounding air it could ignite setting
the lake on fire
but you'd likely already be unconscious
from all that carbon dioxide
your heart rate would increase and if by
some slim chance you were conscious
you'd experience extreme headaches and
dizziness
finding yourself swimming in an
exploding lake kivu wouldn't end well
you'd be looking at anything from carbon
dioxide poisoning getting burnt by
methane infused fire
so get out of that lake as soon as you
can and if you brought some portable
oxygen with you
start breathing it
and maybe drink a glass of water but
don't dare try a sip from lake natron
that's a story for another
what if
[Music]